[Musique]
bonsoir à tous j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à la blog chaîne le jour où
j'ai compris que ce n'était pas qu'une
innovation technique mais le fondement
d'un futur internet de la confiance j'en
suis convaincu
la belote chaîne sera au service de
confiance comme les banques les
assurances même les avocats une
révolution numérique de l'ampleur de
celle que la poste les médias ou les
services de l'information ont connu avec
internet ce qui frappe quand on
s'intéresse à la blocs chaîne et
internet c'est tout d'abord la
similitude entre les valeurs de leur
communauté d'origine
la protection de la vie privée
la remise en cause des tiers de
confiance
le partage et la colo et la
collaboration entre les utilisateurs en
1996 john perry barlow qui
malheureusement nous a quittés il ya
deux mois maintenant a publié un texte
fondateur et historique sur internet sa
déclaration d'indépendance
dans ce texte ils rejetaient la
souveraineté de l'état sur ce nouveau
territoire
en 94 à la même époque les crypto
anarchiste qui allait devenir la
communauté on va dire d'adoption ou de
naissance de bitcoin plus tard ont
publié leur manifeste dans celui ci il
affirme que les gouvernements les
sociétés commerciales et les
organisations sans visage nous nous
accorderons pas une vie privée par acte
de bienveillance un appel
rester sans réponse à régler ce problème
par la technologie est en effet internet
est devenu une zone de pouvoir et une
zone de surveillance
pas très loin de chez nous de l'autre
côté de la manche
une entreprise anglaise cambridge
analytica à manipuler les élections du
bric site ainsi que les élections de la
plus puissante démocratie de la planète
les états unis à l'aide de nos données
facebook à partir des liens entre la
bloque chaîne et internet plusieurs
questions me viennent à l'esprit
la première c est ce que les blocs
chaîne va suivre le même chemin internet
la deuxième c'est ce que la
marchandisation et la concentration
d'internet vont se retrouver sur le blog
chaîne la troisième c est ce que le blog
chaîne va devenir une zone de pouvoir et
une zone de surveillance comme internet
faux répond à cette question je vous
propose de faire un retour dans le passé
et de regarder l'évolution d'internet
par rapport à ces deux-là blocs chaîne
pour internet
tout commence il ya cinquante ans quand
l'armée américaine met en place un
réseau décentralisé capable donc de
résister à une attaque nucléaire afin de
pouvoir communiquer très rapidement des
geeks un peu hippie des libertaires
comprennent que ce réseau leur permettra
de communiquer les uns avec les autres à
l'abri de la censure et de la propagande
je vous rappelle qu'à l'époque nous
sommes en pleine guerre froide pour ces
pionniers
internet devait être le moyen de
concrétiser une liberté d'expression
totale comme internet
bitcoin la première blog chaîne a été
créé pour permettre de s'échanger de la
valeur dans sa forme la plus simple la
monnaie pas comme paypal mais de
s'échanger de la monnaie sans passer par
un tiers de confiance
une banque où l'état bitcoin a été créé
en 2008 et ce n'est pas un hasard 2008
c'est la date de l'une des plus grandes
trahisons des tiers de confiance
la crise des subprimes pendant des
années les banques nous ont assuré que
la situation était sous contrôle et que
tout allait bien elles ont pourtant
provoqué une crise mondiale qui a plongé
dans la misère des millions de gens et
me même des états à genoux et ce sont
nos impôts
à nous les citoyens qui ont sauvé la
finance face à cette trahison la blocs
chaîne ne propose pas une réponse
juridique ou une réponse politique elle
propose une réponse technologique celle
de payer de gérer de la richesse entre
nous sur un réseau qu'ils soient
collectifs sans passer par les banques
justement où les états la blog chaîne
est avant tout un idéal un idéal où
chaque individu serait totalement libres
de gérer sa richesse numérique est
totalement responsable des blocs scène
c'est la promesse d'une indépendance
financière comme internet a été la
promesse d'une liberté d'expression
absolue pourtant internet n'a pas tenu
sa promesse
alors que s'est-il passé à quel moment
l'histoire d'internet at-elle basculé
on le sait aujourd'hui dans les années
90 certaines sociétés ont compris le
phénomène de numérisation du monde
quelle compagnie internet amazon et nés
en 94
à l'époque il vendait des livres google
est né dans un garage en 98 évidemment
en ce temps là personne ne les a pris au
sérieux nous en france ont continué à
utiliser le minitel et le gouvernement
français recevait alors un rapport du
nom de son auteur monsieur terry qui
affirmait qu internet dont le chiffre
d'affaires mondial ne correspond même
pas au 12e de celui du minitel n'était
sûrement pas un bon moyen de faire des
services commerciaux en ligne
on a encore une fois été les précurseurs
pendant ce temps là amazon et google et
facebook ont très bien compris les
nouvelles règles du jeu proposé des
services sans limite à l'échelle de ce
réseau mondial et des services même le
plus souvent gratuits car fonctionnant
sur la collecte de données personnelles
la conséquence est connu ces services
sont devenus des points de passage
obligé et les chiffres aujourd'hui sont
effrayants 95% ce sont les recherches
sur internet que vous faites à l'aide
d'un seul moteur de recherche google 75%
ce sont les revenus de la publicité en
ligne qui tombe dans l'escarcelle de
facebook et google
2020 c'est la date à laquelle on estime
que le chiffre d'affaires cumulé des
gaffes à google amazon facebook et apple
en feront la première puissance
économique mondiale la bonne chaîne elle
aussi ce marchandises
il est loin désormais le temps où les
pionniers du bitcoin de 12 anarchiste
libertaire
ils sont devenus maintenant soit
millionnaires soit chefs d'entreprises
florissantes et surtout ils ont tourné
le dos à leurs idéaux finie la
décentralisation
désormais ils veulent créer des
entreprises centralisée c'est tout le
paradoxe un réseau libre ouvert et
décentralisé peut accueillir des
services qui eux sont centralisés et
concentré c'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement
avec internet vous auriez pu au lieu de
faire vos recherches sur google tapez
directement le nom du site dans la barre
de recherche mais nous passons tous par
google google collecte de données nous
propose un meilleur service et la boucle
est bouclée
aujourd'hui google est devenu la seule
porte porte d'entrée dans le web
et c'est un problème
le même phénomène aujourd'hui se
reproduit dans les blocs chaîne quand
j'ai acheté mon premier bitcoin mon
premier morceau de bitcoin j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un je lui ai donné de
l'argent il m'a donné du bitcoin ça
s'est fait entre nous sans tiers de
confiance
désormais je passe par une plateforme
centralisée aux états unis comme bells
la principale plate-forme d'achat et de
vente de bitcoin au monde compte
désormais plus de 15 millions
d'utilisateurs
c'est dix fois plus qu'il ya deux ans
croissance exponentielle me fait penser
que qu'une baisse va bientôt devenir le
google du bitcoin c'est à dire l'unique
porte d'accès à quoi bon avoir un réseau
décentralisé est libre s'il n'y a qu'une
porte surtout qu évidemment cette
concentration n'est pas compatible avec
les valeurs d'origine de la communauté
blocs sont les services qui étaient
ouverts aujourd'hui sont fermés le
partage et la collaboration ont laissé
la place à la concurrence et à la
consommation pire la protection de la
vie privée et la confidentialité ont
laissé place à l'identification
systématique et à la collecte de données
sybase toujours lui a récemment été
obligés de transmettre plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d' identité au fisc
américain
alors la question fiscale m'intéresse
particulièrement tant qu'avocat peut
vous rasseoir je vais pas vous parler de
fiscalité parce qu'elle nous permet
d'aborder la dernière pierre à l'édifice
de la centralisation c'est la
réglementation la réglementation part
toujours d'un bon sentiment protéger les
consommateurs vous protéger et me faire
travailler mais la réglementation
c'est à dire désagréments c'est
également une barrière entre ceux qui en
profitent
ceux qui sont à gré est ce qu'ils ne
sont pas et cette barrière est d'autant
plus difficile à franchir quand un
agrément peut coûter plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros
alors est ce que cette marchandisation
de la baule chaîne nous mène elle nous
mène à une situation ironique les
services blog chaîne née après la crise
de 2008 vont devenir ce qu'ils ont
toujours dénoncé des banques oui tout
simplement des banques alors évidemment
nous sommes passés de l'utopie à la
marchandisation de la marchandisation à
la concentration et la concentration
c'est une notion qui a à voir avec le
pouvoir ces services aujourd'hui n'ont
ils pas trop de pouvoir sur internet les
jeux sont faits les plateformes
numériques
les cafards ont aujourd'hui un pouvoir
économique qui leur permet de tuer
l'innovation dont ils ont pourtant
profité face à une idée nouvelle ou un
concurrent que fait heins gaffard il
vous propose deux choix je te rachète
c'est ce que facebook a fait avec
instagram en 2015 pour un milliard de
dollars
ou alors je te laisse accéder à ma
plateforme mais soumet conditions sous
mon contrôle
aujourd'hui qui peut lancer un service
quel qu'il soit sans passer par google
facebook youtube ou apple personnes
certains ont essayé ils ont évidemment
eu un problème
proton mail est un service mail qui se
caractérise par un très grand respect de
la vie privée il se pose comme une
alternative à gmail en 2015 google dont
gmail l'a tout simplement retiré des
résultats de recherche non pas pendant
quelques heures en quelques jours mais
pendant dix mois c'est à dire que
pendant dix mois un service numérique a
disparu d'internet service qui
évidemment a presque failli mettre la
clé sous la porte
au final face à ces plateformes
c'est je t'achète ou je te soumets comme
dirait pablo escobar prends mon or ou
prends mon plomb
un pouvoir économique book mais
également un pouvoir sociétales comme
l'a révélé edouard snowdon en 2013 la
formidable machine de surveillance
devenue folle des états unis n'est ce
pionner pas seulement les ennemis de
l'amérique mais également des
gouvernements la france des chefs d'état
angela merkel ou de simples citoyens
peut-être certains d'entre vous ce qui
me choque dans cette affaire n'était pas
qu'un gouvernement
aucun service de renseignement nous
surveiller 90 ça on a l'habitude mais
c'est plus qu ils se sont appuyés sur
des collaborateurs pour le moins
inattendu c'est l'entreprise numérique
chantre de la transparence de
l'horizontalité et de la bienveillance
dont deux pays veulent nous dit google
lab look chaîne connaîtra bientôt ces
géants et rien ne permet de croire que
la bloque chaîne sera à l'abri les
dérives d'internet au fur et à mesure
que la puissance des entreprises blog
shane grandira comment être sûr qu'elle
n'utilisera pas son pouvoir pour tuer
l'innovation pour écarter ses
concurrents pour maximiser ses profits
au fur et à mesure que leur puissance
économique augmentera comment être sûr
qu'elles pourront résister longtemps à
la pression des gouvernements qui leur
demanderont nous surveiller au nom par
exemple de la lutte contre le terrorisme
avec leurs détails près le blog chaîne
est fondée je ne rentre pas dans les
détails sur un registre qui est
transparent et ouvert
sachez juste que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour notre vivre il est au fur
et à mesure que les blocs chaîne entrera
dans nos vies comme elle est entrée
comme internet est entré dans nos vies
avant elle alors les limites au contrôle
et à la surveillance des tiers de
confiance seront de plus en plus
difficiles à fixer
je pense que vous l'avez compris je ne
suis pas très optimiste sur l'évolution
des blocs chaîne elle ne supprimera pas
les tirs de confiance elle en créera de
nouveaux alors que faire quand tout va
mal il faut relire churchill il a dit à
son peuple
si vous oubliez votre passé vous serez
condamné à le revivre
alors j'aimerais vous dire à vous qui
êtes là ce soir également à tout le
peuple du numérique apprenons de notre
négligence coupable avec les géants du
numérique aux utilisateurs d'abord
j'aimerais leur dire
pendant des années nous n'avons pas
prêté suffisamment attention à la
concentration des pouvoirs dans les
mains de quelques géants sur internet
aujourd'hui nous avons une seconde
chance la révolution blocs chaîne est en
effet au stade d'internet dans les
années 90
tout reste à faire donc ouvrez grand les
yeux et surtout adopter un esprit
critique et un esprit politique sur la
technologie
c'est à ce prix que la blog chaîne
pourra faire d'internet un internet de
la confiance je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]